a star-studded dinner a glaring absentee
britain's man in washington disinvited
from dinner last night but it was only
the beginning the diplomat who dined
with trump's inner circle was about to
lose his seat at a few more tables sir
kim derek kept quiet at the british
embassy choosing to opt out of a meeting
with Ivanka Trump to avoid any
awkwardness Liam Fox did make it out but
Sky News understands he didn't offer an
apology
the cables weren't even discussed when
on Capitol Hill the first daughter was
giving nothing away is the Trump
administration dysfunctional do you
agree with your father's decision not to
deal with the British ambassador anymore
can we get a quick word on that please
there was more tumbleweed at the
Commerce Department Wilbur Ross choosing
to cancel his time with Derek and Fox
the man with a packed diary is now left
watching the phone persona non grata in
all but name even if he was not engaging
directly with President Trump he seemed
to have very high-level access to senior
officials within the Trump
administration and if a directive goes
out to them that they are no longer able
to engage with the British ambassador it
makes it very difficult for him to
represent the British government and to
be able to engage effectively
fittingly at the White House a new wall
is being built on a day when we're
reminded just how quickly access can be
taken away the British ambassador has
now enjoyed the sharp end of the Trump
effect publicly humiliated on Twitter
his position called into question and
squeezed out of key events a trio of
embarrassments delivered with great neck
speed but the State Department says it
hasn't been instructed to cut any
contact with the embassy or ambassador
we have an incredibly special and
strategic relationship with the United
Kingdom that has gone on for quite a
long time and it's bigger than any
individual it's bigger than any
government and something that has stood
the test of time and will continue to do
so relationships they were built on
people and the clash of personalities at
the top is doing little to smooth things
over
cordelia Lynch Sky News Washington